hello everyone I only have time for one
upload today but that's the reason I
chose this game as the game is well
nothing short of magical this was played
in 1970 its USSR against the rest of the
world this is round two and Boris
Spassky demolishes as the reigning world
champion at the Danish grandmaster bent
Larsen in 19 moves and I don't know if
this is officially spassky's immortal
game some say that his win in the Kings
gambit against David Bronstein is
spassky's immortal game but I definitely
prefer this one but I'll let you be the
judge of that
so Larson has the white pieces and he
plays b3 the Larson attack will be 5 by
Spassky Bishop to b2 Knight to c6 and c4
we have 90 to f6 and now well already a
move like III or Knight to c3 would be
preferred but to Larson plays Knight to
f3 and allows Spassky to push for we
have a knight to d4 and Spassky plays
Bishop to c5 pretty much forcing Larsson
to capture on c6 we have Knight captures
on c6 and the D captures on c6 and okay
Larsson did double Spassky C pawn here
but you can see that Spassky has this
beautiful Bishop on c5 if2 his light
square bishop is ready to jump into the
attack the Queen is completely open is
well ready to castle this Knight is
ready to jump to jump to g4 this will be
very hard to play for Larsson
we have III as Larsson doesn't really
have an option of developing freely
Bishop to f5 by Spassky preparing to
Castle queenside
and also over protecting this efore pawn
completely denying Larsson any ideas of
d3 or even d4 so Queen to c2 and we have
Queen to e7 preparing to Castle
queenside
Bishop to e2 Spassky castles and we have
f4 Larson tries to develop any way he
can and well this simply isn't enough
Spassky immediately jumps into the
attack he plays Knight to g4 and already
here
it's it's extremely hard for Larson to
find the move for example a simple move
like eliminating this night here on g4
for example Bishop Jefferson g4 with a
bit not Bishop captures on g4 but with
Queen to h4 check and well you pretty
much have to move the King if you play
something like g3 Queen characters on g4
your King will be stuck on Iman for the
rest of the game and well the the black
King side pawns are all ready to be
pushed forward and after Knight to g4
you definitely don't want to play a move
like Knight to c3 this losses
immediately if Knight to c3 is placed
possibly has this resource of playing
rook captures on d2 and after a move
like Queen capture Sundy - you have
Bishop captures on e3 now with an attack
on the Queen and the Queen pretty much
doesn't have anywhere to go
for example if Queen to c2 you get
Bishop to f2 check and no matter where
the King goes Larson loses the Queen for
example King to F 193 with a royal fork
loses the Queen if you go to d1 again 93
loses the Queen and if you go King study
- now III check and opening up an attack
from the bishop on f5 loses the Queen
so after this Knight to g4 move Larson
tried to g3 now stopping any ideas of
Queen to h4 but here
Spassky finds another idea he plays h5
we have h3 by Larson and in this
position well I move like Knight
captures on e3 would be perfectly fine
for Spassky and this would be probably
winning but Spassky finds the mortal
move and he plays h4 and here Larson
really doesn't doesn't have a move
probably the best move would be to
capture the night with the Bishop but
but Larson tries to defend this and he
plays H captures on g4 Spassky plays H
captures on g3 and what do you do here
well what's the idea the idea is if you
capture the bishop on f5 with G captures
on f5 you get rook captures on h1 and
this is terrible for white only move is
to f1 and now g2 and there is no defense
against the G captures on on f1 and
after H captures on g3 if you captured
rook on h8 you get rook captures on h8
and the wall still g2 is a terrible
threat if you play something like it
came to f1 you get to rock the h1 check
King g2 and up Queen to h4 and there is
no defense against checkmate so after H
captors and g3 Larsson tried rook to g1
but now Spassky continues the game in
great style
he plays rook to h1 not threatening rook
captures and g1 Larsson captures the
rook the rook captures and h1 and
sparsely plays g2 now opening up this
Queens diagonal for Queen to h4 check
and here are Larsson played rock to f1
and well capturing the rook would be
perfectly fine for black and this would
be in fact winning but let's see what
happens if rook to g1 is played if rock
did you want a Queen to h4 you have
Kings to d1 and now Queen to h1
threatening to capture the roof in g1
and well what are you gonna do here if
you capture the Queen you get a GG after
sin h1 with Czech Bishop to f1 and Queen
captures on f1 with the checkmate
so after g2 Larsson tried to disrupt f1
idea but of course sparse Spassky didn't
capture the rock he played Queen to h4
would check King to d1 was played now G
captures an f1 with Czech Bishop
captures on f1 and here's Pascal plays
Bishop captures on g4 would check Larsen
played Bishop to e2 and Spassky finished
the game this is move 19 with Queen to
h1 checkmate but it doesn't help if you
play King to see one you simply get into
you wanna check and there is no no more
squares for the White King only movies
Queen to be one and you get Queen
captures on the one with checkmate
but after this three two spots we finish
the game
well elegantly with Queen to h1
checkmate so this is probably of all the
games I've seen by boris spassky this is
this is the most beautiful game
definitely I would like to hear your
opinion if you agree and what is your
favorite game played play by the by the
reigning champion as this was played in
1970 I would like to thank James Norwood
and Arjun Garretson for contribution to
my channel think a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon